before i begin i feel it is necessary to
point out that the news arm of the bbc
has yet to retract apologize or
otherwise address the deeply transphobic
reporting it has engaged in in the last
few months in a pinned comment down
below you'll find my original video on
the topic several videos from the
youtuber sean who has been ongoing in
his pursuit of trying to get the bbc to
own up to what they have done and also a
video from laura kate dale showing the
protests that have taken place outside
of the bbc offices while i don't feel
any of the people behind doctor who are
in any way responsible for this i cannot
in good conscience talk about a bbc
owned property without mentioning this
first until such time as it is properly
redressed thank you
you know
i've always hated riding the bus
[Music]
continuing on with my re-watch of series
11 and we've arrived at
rosa
now this is an episode that i already
have a little bit of an odd history with
because this isn't technically a
second
review on it this is
a third
when the episode first came out i gave
my initial thoughts after watching it
and i was mixed about it
and something just wasn't sitting right
with me once i realized what that was i
made a second video
following up on that and so
since then
i haven't come back and watched it again
and i know a lot of people
really
really love this episode so
i
i'm gonna be honest i was nervous to
kind of come back and
see how well my thoughts on it
previously both my initial and my
secondary thoughts
actually held up
and
some of them do and those that are a
little bit more iffy i'm like i do get
why i felt that way i suppose the main
thing that i'm going to want to address
we'll get to it when i start talking
about that part of the episode
is the ending and the fact that the
doctor and the companions are on the bus
just to watch
so i had some very strong feelings about
that around the time that it aired but
we'll get back to that
my overall opinion on this episode is
that it is
incredibly well-meaning
the actress who plays rosa is
very good
but it's still
kind of clunky in its execution i
appreciate a lot of what it's doing
and
some of it is even done well but other
parts of it just
feel
off
some of its little logistical touches
some of it's stuff that like just as a
storyteller setting any message or
intent behind the story aside that's
just like wait what why would you do
that and then there's just how
deliberate
many of the bits of information being
conveyed feel and what i mean by that is
it feels very much at times like a
school
lesson and i want to be very specific
about that i'm not saying that in a way
that it seems like it's being
patronizing or that i think it is
talking down to its audience that's not
what i mean which is often what uh
people tend to mean when they say
something sounds like a lecture or
anything along those lines
but between the doctor at one point
busting out a pen to write on a wall the
specific date and she literally says
what do you remember about rosa from
school
it
feels like a course refresher more than
anything else and unfortunately this is
kind of reiterated with the way the
information of what happened to rosa
after her arrest on the bus is delivered
and in june 1999
rosa receives a congressional medal from
president clinton
which again is just the doctor telling
the companions in a way that i
practically expect her to say at the end
now i hope you are all taking notes this
will be on the quiz again i'm not saying
that it's bad because it's patronizing
i'm saying it's
awkward because it just doesn't feel
like part of a narrative
it doesn't feel integrated it feels like
let's pause the narrative
to deliver all of the
main bullet points from a history lesson
and that's not necessarily against the
spirit of doctor who at least in theory
because the show was originally
conceived as something to be somewhat
educational but
it still isn't
integrated or executed particularly
smoothly
that having been said the general idea
of really dealing head-on was something
that dr who knew who in particular has
largely kind of dodged which is
just the issues of some of these uh
companions ending up in some of the time
periods they do and that's
potentially a problem it's dodged around
with episodes like say the shakespeare
code it's addressed a little bit in
terms of something like say human nature
and the family of blood but honestly
it's only a couple of lines there
referring to martha's race it seems to
largely be a class thing since the
friend that she has who's also made is
white like the most head on that doctor
who modern era doctor who well classic
doctor who really never dealt with it
full stop but the closest that modern
doctor who's come to dealing with i
would say was thin ice uh but even then
it was largely around just the villain
and one more thing to hate that guy over
and while i did really like that and i
will never get tired of watching that
guy get punched in the face
it wasn't a really a core essential part
of the story again
while the dude was a racist for the most
part his issue seemed to be classism as
he thought well anybody of any race is
disposable if they are of less means
than me
so this is really dealing with the
racism of the past much more head on
which
i don't think that's a bad thing to try
and do especially given that the show's
really gone out of its way to kind of
dodge dealing with that fully
properly directly the closest it's come
has been a ton of allegorical stuff
sure with alien races and situations etc
but let's deal with the reality i can
respect the idea certainly there are
just some odd moments that just
feel off to me so like for example
when the fam first run into rosa parks
and they hear her name the fact that
they all squeeze vocally at her rosa
parks
no way you kidding brilliant
rosa parks lovely to meet you rosa parks
big fan three quarters of the tardis
team just going in this whole uh sort of
fangirl mode
vocally to her face to me it's just it's
it's uncomfortable and also it just
reads weird
like my my gun instinct is to be like
trust your actors to just put it on the
face
like they're going to be like
yeah no really pleased to meet you and
then the instant she's out of ear
shopping like oh my god that was rosa
parks to have them just blurted out just
again it feels it feels clunky it feels
like an awkward way to do something that
like there's better ways to do that oh
and just so we're clear it's bad when
any doctor does this charles dickens
you're brilliant you are completely 100
brilliant i give a christy i was just
talking about you the other day i said i
bet she's brilliant the conversation
between yaz and ryan in the alley is not
quite as um clunky on the nose as say
the fan-girling moment or the sort of
school
lesson sort of moments but it's not
that far off as well and like here's the
thing the points that they bring up
all super valid and i can buy that the
essence of the conversation that they're
having
is very
reasonable that in these circumstances
this is the kind of conversation and the
kinds of points that these characters
would have you know i can't believe
we're dealing with this things did get
better but man not as much better as
they should have like well you know in
so much time this stuff will get better
where will we be after that so like if
you were to bullet point out the
things brought up in the conversation i
go awesome go write that conversation
but it's not a very
well in flowing conversation it still
works a little bit better than sort of
the school lesson moments because i at
least buy that under the circumstances
where they are they would be having that
conversation at that time it's just it
is d it feels like it's dealing with
bullet points for here are the things we
need to be sure get addressed and said
but the actual
move to turn it into a conversational
bit of dialogue
that step wasn't taken
and there are little moments that sort
of give me glimmers of like what would
have felt
more natural and conversational like at
the very end of that interaction in the
alley yaz says
must be my mexican blood
and that feels much more natural because
it's bringing up again the fact that to
these people these racist white people
they don't really care whether
she's mexican or pakistani or anything
else they can tell she's not just black
but other than that like lump them all
together who cares and that's a bit of
conversational dialogue that like okay
you that makes and brings up the point
without flatly saying
the point because the clunky way to say
that would have been for her to go
well
at least they're not confusing you for a
different race they keep saying i'm
mexican like well yeah we saw that but
by having it be that line of must be my
mexican blood it's referencing this
thing reminding us of this thing making
this point but it's like actual dialogue
the other thing that actually i think
was integrated actually very well and
incredibly
naturally and conversationally were the
references to grace
so that gets brought up after they sort
of have their little classroom session
in the hotel but they talk about her
then and with graham and ryan and that
conversation feels perfectly natural she
had a t-shirt that said um
spirit of rosa i wish that she was here
i don't she'd stop her right
that is the
warmth natural conversational sort of
feel that i wish had been injected into
i don't know if it could have been
injected into every bit of these
interactions i'm talking about but more
of them because that
does something that is a bullet point
which is
bring up grace the fact that these two
are still in mourning over her and how
she influenced both of their
perspectives on civil rights and the
past and things like that
it accomplishes that bullet point
in a way that is naturally delivered in
a flowing bit of dialogue that makes
sense for the characters and feels like
a real conversation
and i
wish that was true of more of these
moments and these scenes now i know
there's a lot of people who kind of
complain about craz code the villain so
here's the thing the core idea of him i
actually think is fine there's a lot of
weird little tiny logistical things that
like do not track with him at all i'll
get to those in a second but i've seen a
lot of people mock the idea basically
calling him him a space racist
here's the thing though if you're trying
to make the argument like people that
far in the future wouldn't still be
racist
why not
racism isn't rational
it's not logical its existence is
emotional
why would we assume that people wouldn't
still have misguided emotional thoughts
you know there are it's like people who
argue there'll be no religion in the
future like why
not
will religion have to evolve and change
in some way yeah probably but why would
people simply stop having faith
and i'm kind of the same way like why
would people simply stop being racist
now the
percentage of people being racist
ideally will continue to drop but
there's always going to be some
by
logic like at this point we know
scientifically there is no difference
between races it is a social construct
there is the visible difference of skin
tone and there is the
social difference of cultural background
but at a core basic genetic level there
is no real significant difference we
know that we have known that for a long
time racism doesn't suddenly go away
so i have no problem with the idea of
someone from the future who is not only
still racist but is going to have this
thinking of it was when you people
stepped out of your lane and didn't know
your place anymore that's where
everything went wrong so that's what i'm
going to change that honestly
if you've ever
had a conversation with someone with
very messed up racial thinking
and if you have had that conversation
you have my sympathy but if you have
ever had a conversation with somebody
like that
that train of thought is not as
outlandish as it seems
so i have no issues with him in concept
in execution there's a whole bunch of
logistical nuts and bolts that like
don't track at all so like for instance
let's take both his weapon and the
neural restrictor that's supposed to
stop him from hurting people okay so
thing number one
this weapon that he has that just blasts
people into the past
so that is something that when he tries
to shoot the doctor with it later on he
gets one shot off and then it overheats
but earlier we saw him firing shot after
shot after shot at them and they had to
run away so this thing is crazy and
consistent for a start and then with the
whole neural restrictor thing i
understand logistically why it's there
they had to explain why he didn't just
kill rosa parks when he got here and so
they're they basically give him the chip
that spike had in buffy the vampire
slayer was like you can't
you know hurt people except like he was
firing that
time displacing weapon
at the doctor and the companions with
intent so if he can fire it at them then
he should be able to fire it at rosa and
i'm guessing that must be indirect
enough
like that doesn't strictly kill them but
it could send them to a time period
where other things might kill them who
knows
so
like there's that so if he can fire it
at them why can't she f why can't he
fire it at her that doesn't really track
by and large crasco as a character feels
and the specifics about him feel reverse
engineered which is something i've
already kind of brought up about the the
feeling of this series in general which
is
they
it feels like they went from a point of
okay we're gonna do something on rosa
parks someone's trying to disrupt
history and stop rosa parks from being
arrested on that bus because of what it
kicks off from there so uh if that's
what they decided the pitch was then
they would have had to go okay
so
why wouldn't this person have just
killed them well then we'll have to put
some neural restrictions in their head
okay
but
if even with that if they're just trying
to disrupt history there's so many
things that they could do
that we still need to get rid of them
somehow okay what if we
have them with a time displacing weapon
that ryan could use on them i'll come
back to that
and
like it all just feels like starting
from a case of well if we want to do
this story we need this this and this we
need to make sure this this and this
doesn't happen and block this and this
from being possibilities and then put
that information
in uh into you know the writer's room
and poof you get crasco he doesn't
feel
like these elements of his character are
thought out beyond
how does this allow the story to happen
and
strictly speaking that's not a problem
in and of itself it's not a problem that
it is reverse engineer and it might not
be honestly i'm kind of presuming the
issue is that it feels that way this is
what is sometimes referred to as seeing
the hand of the author where it's not
the decisions themselves that are the
issue but you
it feels like a decision made by a
writer rather than a natural progression
of character or story so you see
the hand of the author being like and
adjust that there we go cool keep going
so that's kind of the issue going on
with him now i said i'd come back to
ryan and the weapon first of all why
does the doctor explain to ryan how this
thing works like in the hotel yes how it
works and she literally tells him how to
use it charges here this setting dials
the temporal destination
pretty simple pretty deadly now can we
concentrate what what what
why did you tell him how to use that and
then he does use it
and more to the point he uses it he
blasts crasco back to the stone age for
all we know
and this never
ever
comes up again
not even really in this episode
a companion
takes a weapon that the doctor earlier
explicitly said she does not like and
it's a nasty piece of work and who
explicitly says to him don't touch that
uses it
to blast a villain into the far distant
past which
that is a bad thing like that's what the
weeping angels do
so if you're just trying to frame that
as a as a heroic or acceptable
alternative to just killing him i'm not
sure that tracks with the associations
of that kind of action and then he just
tells the doctor yeah i did that and it
never
ever
comes up again
i've got a
big problem with that and like i'm not
going to say what should have come of
that whether the doctor should have
started
distrusting ryan i'm not i'm don't think
crasco should have like somehow come
back because he wasn't strictly killed
by that move or anything like that but
that feels like that should have some
kind of consequences
on the interpersonal relationships of
the characters if nothing else
but it doesn't the doctor doesn't even
react
and like if the doctor had had some
reaction even if she like had this sort
of little sideways knowing glance or
something maybe i could have had candida
where she kind of wanted him to do this
but didn't want to say it outright and
it's like a little bit of that 10th
doctor you know manipulating people
against their own interest or to do the
thing that like you're not uh
you don't want to do on your own
that he did every now and then what some
doctors have but like tenth went on
about the fact that he did that a bit
so
i uh i can't even headcan in that cause
there isn't the wiggle room to do it
so
it doesn't bother me that ryan did it it
bothers me that there is
zero fallout and zero consequences to
that on him as a character on his
relationship with the doctor practically
logistically
no consequences to that
what
and when i say consequences i'm not
saying like ryan needed to be punished
but as i said this mirrors something
done by villainous beings that are some
of the scariest things in doctor who the
doctor said specifically she hates these
weapons she has chided people already
for picking up weapons or kicking people
off of uh cranes and she has no reaction
to this
it's just like
what what what
what
is going on so now we're kind of getting
towards
the stuff where i had very complicated
feelings before
so
first off
i actually find it interesting
and i'm not sure if it's inherently good
or bad but it is interesting
that the way this episode is constructed
it is kind of saying that
the bad people of history
are just as important as the heroes of
history because it's not enough to
ensure that rosa got on that bus it had
to be james blake driving
now you could make the argument that it
was about specifically preserving the
timeline in as complete as a sense as
possible
but
the ultimate outcome of that is
well
the villain of the moment
needed to be there
in order for the hero of the moment
to
have what happened happened
and that's interesting to me i don't
think it's making any sort of deliberate
or moral
judgment around that it's just kind of
an interesting
acknowledgement i kind of like it but
then we get to
the the very end where the doctor and
the companions
are on the bus to witness all this now
let me back up and sort of summarize my
issues
with this previously
my
problem that i had that that i settled
on because when i did my initial review
i didn't quite know
why it was sitting so badly with me
um and then when i did i did the second
video because i figured it out
what i realized was it made me
deeply uncomfortable and deeply unhappy
that
the episode could
i don't believe this was ever an
intention
could be read
as the people
who were not the oppressed
having to just sit there
and bear witness
but not help and yes i understand
logistically they couldn't help
timelines and all that but my issue was
that ultimately
pulled the logistics of the story aside
what is
happening the people with privilege
sit by
and ha and watch as the people
struggling and oppressed pull themselves
up
don't help
just observe
and that
just reminded me of the most infuriating
kind of allyship
where people stand at the sides and go
we're rooting for you but do nothing
that
is not
meaningless
but it's not enough and it's not what's
needed
and at the time uh to put it in more
specific context
the weekend of that i saw this episode
was the same weekend that then president
trump
implemented
it as official federal guidelines to
treat gender
as
something assigned at birth and
immutable and unchangeable now this
didn't change national policy but
within federal institutions
federal
government offices were instructed by
him and his administration to treat
gender that way
and that
set me off a bit
so seeing people like me directly
targeted was not a good time for me to
watch an episode where i came away with
the feeling that the people who could be
doing something
were choosing not to and that was
depicted as noble
i was not okay with that
rewatching it now some years later
there is an aspect of it that i think i
didn't give its due credit that kind of
counterbalances that old read that i had
which is that
it's not just that they're they're not
sitting there for the heck of it
their presence
is
a manner of helping
because
if they don't stay there the bus isn't
full enough
for the bus driver to demand that rosa
parks give up her seat
and so
this is kind of the middle ground that i
think under the circumstances is the
best that could be reached
between we need to preserve this moment
of in history
and we can't screw with it
but
let's have the characters do something
it didn't really
click with me before that in the very
specific
circumstances
that these characters are in
the choice to even be there
was still an active choice
that did help and did make a difference
now
i still worry that anybody might come
away with even a subtextual feeling that
simply being present and taking no
action is enough in and of itself
that's not what i would want but
under the logistical constraints of the
story they were telling
i think i felt that the characters were
more passive than they actually are
even that passivity that they have to
sit there and watch it is something they
have to choose to do
that and to watch this happen is a pain
they choose to experience is it
uh
in any way equal to what rosa's going
through no
but the show doesn't pretend like it is
either so while i'm not going to say
that my previous read and my more
negative read on that moment
specifically was
wrong it was very informed by stuff
going on and my feelings about that
stuff at the time and it leaned me more
firmly into a negative read than i think
is entirely fair
and so i feel
better about that moment now certainly
than i did
when i did my second video on this some
years ago
now that having been said there are
still a couple of other clunky bits
towards the end
there's the um rise up song that plays
kind of it sort of starts playing
um you know when rose is confronting the
bus driver you know through her arrest
and they keep it going after that it's
very on the nose
i'm kind of okay with it though if only
because i like it better than the
generically inspirational horn sting
that they keep cutting in
it's which sounds like something out of
the freaking west wing which i also hate
the music from the west wing so
like
is about the one time i can think that
i'm really down on the music in the
chibnall and whitaker era of doctor who
i don't
i don't like that you that this this
generic
horn sting
i hate it i it really really really
bothers me and it does not feel like it
fits the moment at all it feels like
again the hands of the authors being
like
super inspirational person super
inspirational moments i'm like yeah let
them be that
don't give me this generic inspiration
soundtrack
so i'm actually okay with the rise up
song because as on the nose as that is
it's better than those freaking horns
were
so
i don't i don't mind that song too much
uh that said choosing to end
on the asteroid
i still think that's weird asteroid
284 996
also known as rosa parks
the asteroid is real there is really an
asteroid named after rosa parks and that
is cool
it's just really strange to me that
that's the last thing to note on i guess
they thought well like it's spacey and
doctor who does space stuff and we'll
end on an image of it i'm like okay but
like you're going for like
you know she was she was uh kind of
an activist all her life she was
recognized as an icon for freedom she
got the congressional medal of honor oh
and also there's a rock in space named
after her
that's just a weird one to decide to be
the last one to decide to be the big
inspirational thing and to end on an
image of a floating rock with the song
going rise up and
disconnect
again like the fact that she has an
asteroid named after her is cool it's
just a weird one to end on at least to
me oh and one last thing about rosa
again very well performed and i do like
that they acknowledge her interest and
her history of being involved in
um early civil rights uh
movements and and leaders at the time
even though like her being arrested on
the bus wasn't planned she was a part of
that world and i like that that's
acknowledged because a big part of the
mistelling of history for a very long
time like the version i was told as a
kid growing up was that she was just a
woman who was tired and wouldn't give up
her seem like no she was someone who
knew what was going on knew what was
wrong and cared now that didn't make
this a planned staged protest moment it
wasn't
but
she was no stranger to the world of
civil rights activism and i like that
that gets acknowledged here that's well
done
so i think i probably come away feeling
better about this episode overall than i
did because my issues previously
kind of ran
um through some of the deeper layers in
terms of the way certain things are
brought across and the messaging
particularly in that final bit
i'm now much more okay with those than i
have been
there's still some logistical
like what the hecks and i
it bothered me even at the time
that there were no consequences to ryan
blasting crasco but it bothers me even
more now because i now have the
hindsight of knowing it never comes up
again
ever
and that's
that is bizarre to me
oh well
rosa
i think i come away liking it overall a
little bit better than i did previously
which is
nice what do you think about it whatever
your thoughts are drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it like
share subscribe patreon that's how i pay
the bills uh and keep this whole
operation up and running any amount is
of great help but don't worry about it
too much all the other stuff helps me
out as well there's other things that i
do or merch or books that i've written
etc links in the description but
don't worry too much about any of it
because what i really want you to
remember
is that you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are
loved you're the council i'm just
running the meetings and until next time
this council
is adjourned
[Music]
and credits i gotta shout out my top
patreon supporters so thank you very
much to zubin luthfullah barack oliver
bean melinda walters lyotha boy tt for
knobby lax the poodle idol tracy
scrabbat vincent paul bartolucci angry
casper adam lefty taylor shane ross
robin moore shayla gourley and brendan
the rose
couldn't do it without you
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]